health and wellness starts to become as
infectious as to these why because it's
in the field it's in Consciousness and
you're witnessing the evidence in
three-dimensional reality that's so
powerful really well it makes me think
about time and I think about like
talking to Greg Braden and talking about
and maybe you guys have had this
conversation
um about just time and you've surely had
this experience though and time
accelerating and speeding up and I'm
wondering if there's any thoughts around
that or like any scientific data or just
or like anecdotal even with your
experience and what you're seeing that
and how important it is to Anchor new
realities like we've been talking about
from the field because of this
acceleration of time and now I'm not
saying I know that scientifically or
factually I'm just saying it feels like
it it feels like things are speeding up
whether it's the veil thinning creating
um waking up uh it just feels like that
so what have you experienced
um I'll explain for me I'll explain it
in two ways I mean one of the ways is
unfortunately technology is actually
causing us to experience more things in
a shorter amount of time okay yeah yeah
we can do so much more in a shorter
amount of time and the side effect of
that unfortunately is that attention
spans have shortened because you can
shift your attention from one thing to
the next and if you keep doing something
over and over again you develop a habit
so
so to the person who is in
three-dimensional reality because of
Technology you can get more done in a
shorter amount of time or more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time so that so there's an equipening in
human consciousness because
the pace has increased right the problem
with that is that you can get on Amazon
Prime and you get something delivered to
your door the next day or sometimes even
the same day there's this kind of
entitlement of convenience that takes
place where we really think that you
know everything's going to be handed to
us or we can get whatever we want
nothing's wrong with that that's really
cool that's really great but in the
creative process
you actually have to get outside of time
in order for you to be able to create
because if you're trying to predict
what's going to happen in the next
moment if you keep Romancing what
happens you're not in the present moment
The Familiar past is the known the
predictable future is the known
the present moment is the unknown that
is where all possibilities exist so
yes there is a function of
three-dimensional reality and Technology
where more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time certainly there's
some type of energetic thing that's
taking place uh in so many ways and to
me that energy is actually endorsing
whoever you want to be that's what I
believe so if you want to be a victim
get ready because it's going to get
really good for you because that energy
is more available if you want to heal
wow there's a lot of people healing now
and they're using that energy
instrumentally in a positive way so so
yes there's a quickening that's taking
place and it's creating quite a contrast
or extremes that are taking place in
reality and the more extreme it gets the
more unstable the system right so uh
governments
um
um
journalism
education religion medicine
uh everything's kind of falling apart
you know um and and it's very obvious to
people that has to happen for a new
Consciousness to emerge the thing is
we can't face these changes
uh programmed because we'll just add to
uh the chaos we actually have to be
relaxed and awake instead of stressed
out and unconscious and we have the data
to show that when you're relaxed and
awake amazing things can actually happen
to you instead of in survival stressed
out and in a program so in order to
create out something new we got to be we
got to be in the present moment and we
have to be outside that pace of where
everything's moving very quickly and and
Technology unfortunately is causing
people it's causing people to think uh
uh instead of them for them to think on
their own and I'm concerned about that
because
um
I never tell people what to think I I
want them to think for themselves I
think it's really important for us to
think for ourselves so there's an
acceleration that's taking place
energetically but I do think that that
acceleration is really just endorsing uh
uh who who you're being so Master the
moment and and learn how to be a Creator
uh I think that amazing things happen
and that's exactly what we're
discovering over and over again in just
witnessing the the science
is absolutely supporting that that you
are greater than you think more powerful
than you know more unlimited than you
can ever dream we have the data over and
over again that suggests that and the
testimonials that we have in hundreds of
people we have cancer researchers
standing on the stage with cancer
completely gone we see stage four
Cancers and bones and organs and liver
in the lungs com metastatic cancer just
doesn't typically go away
um very easily and out of the bones
there's no sign of it anywhere I mean
not once not twice over and over again
we had two people at an event that were
blind I mean no
you know I'm you know I'm a healthy
skeptic I mean this woman saw her face
for the first time in the mirror and
crazy too too good of a story to pass up
you can't make these up so
the testimony is the four minute mile
what was once considered impossible I
mean muscular dystrophy really the
Physicians that were in the audience
that were disbelievers they they were in
tears they just could not imagine that
this could actually take place it wasn't
matter to matter you know it wasn't 3D
reality trying to change 3D reality that
was not it was it was energy that was
actually informing about it I could
never do it that way it had it had
happened another way so you have this
amazing evidence in scientific research
and you have this amazing evidence in
human testimony and evidence is the
loudest voice and I'm so optimistic now
for the first time in a long time that
we actually can actually find our way
here that that that we have to come
together community
of the same Consciousness that isn't
angry they've overcome their anger it
isn't fearful they've overcome their
fear they're not suffering in pain
they've overcome that in their own
personal work and they're actually
showing the world what love looks like
they're showing the world what greatness
looks like they're demonstrating for the
world they're not talking about it
philosophically they're actually
demonstrating who they are so the person
who witnesses them says wow something is
really
different about you what's different
about you I don't know well there's
something different about you because
the person is not
the the person who's perceiving them
doesn't match their memory of them any
longer there's something different about
the person and that's exactly what this
world needs that Collective networks of
observers determine reality do you
believe in 100 monkey Theory I do I'm
actually I'm not it's not that I believe
it and I know it now because I'm seeing
four people with Raynard syndrome in one
event all heal I mean I mean that is
that is a collective that's a
morphogenic what's the possibility that
we see the hundredth monkey Theory uh
come into effect on our level of
Consciousness globally within our
lifetime I think as we get close as the
time speeds up like it is it gets more
and more unpredictable to determine when
it's going to happen but I will tell you
this I'm so optimistic if we can
continue uh staying awake relaxed and
awake and continually doing the work and
keep pushing the edge of what's possible
the brain it's really funny you know the
brain actually changes
the most when you get to the point where
you think you can't go any further if
you go past that point if you just go
past that point that's when you see the
greatest brain changes and so we
actually push people past that point and
we give them some tools what to do there
and lo and behold we we see young people
old people we see it educated uneducated
we see a healthy sick I mean it doesn't
matter it's uh because none of that
matters it's just it's it's just their
their ability to be able to execute so
it's the reprogramming it's com it's
it's it's like unprogramming
reprogramming it can you know when you
you know use a fire what wall service to
you know burn things down it's Alchemy
too right it's some sort of
alchemical process happening where you
are like short-circuiting something and
growing something new and growing pains
are called that for a reason well let's
say let's make it really simple if we
are pure love if you're on the journey
anything that is not love and you must
die or in order for you to find true or
true love pure love a part of you must
die and I think that's the difference
between knowing the path uh and walking
the path walking the path is really what
it's about right how do you as you move
through your life and you have done such
phenomenal things and continue to do
more and more how do you get your
information to know what comes next like
where what direction to turn your head
to turn your energy where does that come
from and in what form
um well I never planned on doing any of
this really
um yeah and my theory from the very
beginning is uh when when this kind of
started become of interest to people I
just said to my staff
um here's how it's gonna work um I'll
only go where I'm invited if I'm not
invited I'll be a chef I'll do something
else and so so
um I'm constantly building my model of
what I understand and I'm like you
always have a thousand questions now I
had so much better for me to sit down
and take a few minutes instead of
turning on my phone or doing it I
actually like the process of
contemplation I like the process of
saying to myself so what do you know
at what point or at what point do you
stop believing that this is the truth
let's get right to that point
and let's let's build that understanding
so I'm constantly building my model
and then I'm tearing it down and then
I'm challenging and building it up again
and if I can't find like there's
something that doesn't fit then I gotta
find information somewhere that makes it
fit that makes sense to me but then it's
not enough for me there then I gotta
like then I gotta experience it like
someone said to me so what someone said
to me yesterday so what are you doing in
your morning meditations I'm like well
it's really funny because I'm I'm
actually developing a new understanding
a new model and I want to teach it at
the follow-up uh next month and
I'm actually practicing this this new
meditation to have the experience so
that I can teach it better so if I can
have the experience of that knowledge
and the model that I build I know the
journey and I can teach it much better
so I work really hard
it being the example of of what I teach
and I work really hard at getting
information either from uh well
references or whatever but also the
information that I love to get that
comes to me when I start connecting and
then it all kind of makes sense and so I
think of many ways as I can to teach it
but I also love to have the experience
because when I have the experience that
I can really teach it on a much deeper
level
[Music]
foreign